This Dnews episode is brought to you by Domain
Dot Com!
Someone on the DNews team recently posed the
question, “What happens to you if you fall
into a black hole?”
As it turns out, horrible, horrible, awesome,
horrible stuff.
Hey there space cadets, I’m Julian, welcome
to another episode of DNews.
Today we’re going to talk about Black Holes,
itty bitty single points in space with so
much mass that even light cannot travel fast
enough to escape their gravitational pull.
Supermassive black holes are at the center
of galaxies and they are enormously massive,
billions times more so than our sun.
Stellar black holes are much smaller and are
the remnants of ex-stars.
And you thought your ex was clingy.
Don’t worry though, the closest stellar
black hole to us, Cygnus x-1, is over 6000
light years away and would only really be
dangerous if you got within 14 thousand miles
of it.
Phew.
I should say Cygnus is a black hole candidate,
it’s kind of hard to detect black holes
because they swallow light and we can’t
see them directly.
So what happens if you cross that threshold
into a supermassive black hole?
You’ll have gone over the event horizon,
and from there there’s no going back and
things get freaky-deaky.
Let’s assume you jumped in head first, because
you’re the adventurous sort.
Even though your head is just a few feet from
your….
feet…. the force of gravity is way stronger
on it.
At first you wouldn’t notice anything, but
as you get close to the center your head gets
pulled and squished, your whole body gets
stretched out.
The technical term is, “spaghettified.”
Nope, that was not one of my bad jokes.
Eventually you’re just a stream of atoms
on your way to join the singularity.
With stellar black holes this will happen
to you long before you cross the event horizon,
so someone could actually watch you get stretched
out.
They’d have to wait a while though.
As you accelerate and get near a massive object,
time for you slows down compared to a stationary
observer that’s much farther away.
you wouldn’t notice it for yourself, but
everyone else would seem to be aging really
fast.
If someone wanted to watch you fall into a
supermassive black hole, they couldn’t.
As you got closer, to them you would be moving
more and more slowly.
Right at the edge of the horizon you would
seem to stop.
You would get dimmer and turn red as the light
waves you reflect gets pulled and stretched,
eventually becoming too long to see.
You would fade to black.
And if movies have taught me anything, that’s
always the best way to end it.
Whoa hey I’m not done yet!
I have to tell you that no domain extension
will help you tell your story like a DOT COM
or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s domain names and web
hosting when you use the coupon code DNEWS
at checkout.
If you want to learn more about time dilation,
Trace covers that for you in this video right
here.
Would you jump into a black hole?
Let us know in the comments!
Please don’t though, because we like having
you around.
Thanks for watching DNews!
Ok, NOW you can fade.